well,
one man is dead and another
is on the run after a shooting in the
west of the valley hello, how are you,
andrés gonzález greets you with his brief
news nao in spanish this happened in
the parking lot of a business near
gran caen en y flamingo the authorities
they say they both started arguing
and suddenly one opened fire
anyone with information is asked to
call the police
the clark county school district board of directors
will meet to
discuss several proposals on their agenda
this week one of them is the decision
of  continue or not with the position of jesús
jara as superintendent of the
school district after having given his
statements to jara he was fired
three weeks ago after a vote of 43
his last day is supposed to be December 1
irene cepeda who originally voted
to fire
Hannah Pie to reassess this decision after a new
round of voting
and if you have not yet been vaccinated you can do so.
er inside the mccarran airport since
there will be some clinics this month one
will be on tuesday the 16th and the other on
november 23 remember that it is in terminal
1 on the second floor they will only operate
from 1 to 3 in the afternoon and the dose of
vaccines against  intercourse are
available for ages 12
and up and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny sky with
temperatures close to 80 degrees by
the afternoon and we will see some clouds pass by
the temperatures will drop by the middle
of the week so put on your winter
coat  new have a nice day
health andrés gonzález
information consumption of industry or in Spanish